what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so keeping on with our whole x-men
chronology for the next few videos we're
gonna be covering Wolverine Origins just
because when you go through the
chronological order of the x-men you
pick up with like new x-men or I guess
new mutants really it's kind of what it
is it's really called new x-men but it's
basically new mutants you pick up with
like uncanny x-men follow the greys and
then you go into like three stories of
Wolverine Origins now this is kind of
weird because I feel like I've done this
before I know we did origins and endings
and that picks up immediately after
house of him and is basically what
happens when Wolverine first gains his
memories back which does come out of the
after effects that happen instead of him
losing his powers he regained all his
memories but that goes into like the
formation of the Muramasa blade which of
course is one of the only blades that's
out there that's capable of shutting off
the healing factor of Wolverine if it's
plunged into him and left there for any
real measure of time and so because of
that I was going through and I was like
did I feel like I've done this before
but I searched all over my channel and I
haven't able to find it so it may just
be one of those things where it's like I
read through it a whole bunch of times
or something along those lines and it
just feels like deja vu but regardless
of the circumstance Wolverine Origins by
daniel way is one of these stories that
Marvel produced where it got mixed
reviews on one side you had Wolverine
traditionalist people who didn't want to
see things change and who liked the way
Wolverine had been progressed over the
years in this publication Wolverine
while you've won Wolverine vol 2 his run
and Claremont's x-men all those
different things that have been fleshed
out the weapon X story you know the 12
issue limited series on the other side
you had people who kind of said
Wolverines origin is an absolute mess
like you have to go through all these
comics you have to read you know three
four hundred comics in order to be able
to gain his overall origin and so it was
easier if it's all just in a concise
location overall the idea is at a desk
consolidate things it basically goes
through the whole origin of Wolverine
introducing his son all the things he'd
done in his past when he first met
Deadpool all those things go into this
great big huge fifty-some-odd issue
thing I think was 56 issues and I kept
them rough taught my head but it goes
into all this stuff but initially this
basically just kind of picks up with
Wolverine kind of going on this mission
of sorts because remember with him
regaining his memories but what Daniel
Way does is he grabs a lot of the things
that we know and then he makes up things
that we didn't know about and then just
kind of throws them all into this comic
and so what we actually end up doing
here is picking up where the Secretary
of Defense or whatever it is for the
president United States there we go
and the whole idea behind this is that
it basically just sort of coincides with
Wolverine breaking into the
white house now this is a huge deal the
idea of Wolverine breaking into the
White House is huge because it's
designed to say two things the first is
that he's brazen that he's really like a
man on a mission but the other half is
to show the ingenuity the stealth the
guile and the kind of espionage that
Wolverine is involved in because
remember for a guy that's lived for a
couple hundred years he's seen and done
it all for the most part I mean he's
fought in various Wars he fought
alongside Captain America - as part of
Weapon X he worked with the CIA as part
of Team X he's very well versed and how
to infiltrate places that are not
supposed to be accessible now All Hands
are on deck here the president's Secret
Service response the military responds
and shield response and so Wolverine has
in the blink of an eye
become the most wanted man in America by
finding a way to get into the White
House at the same time somebody fired a
missile that offered some measure of a
distraction now it wasn't designed to
actually hit the White House the missile
was basically designed to take
everyone's attention away from the
actions of Wolverine so that's why it's
kind of a big deal because when it comes
to shield their main goal is to
basically maintain safety in the United
States but monitor all these different
threats different things like that and
where Wolverine is a blip on a radar
where suddenly someone's in the White
House that that's not supposed to be
there and the Secret Service is
responding a missile comes flying in
that's where right it begins to panic
and everybody begins to scramble but
with Wolverine making his way in there
what he immediately does is seemingly go
after this secretary now along that's
because of the fact that what's
established here is that she's not
supposed to be there though she's
basically working for another agency
where Wolverine goes after her he's
basically met by the arrival of a Shiva
which was stationed inside the rocket
which the crash landed on the grounds of
the White House now the Shiva's are
pretty interesting they're basically
robots but they were designed for the
purpose of tracking down and
neutralizing members of the Weapon X
program that went rogue that's one of
the reasons why Wolverines memories were
kind of scrambled for a time is because
over the course of the Weapon X project
what you had before Wolverine is you
would have people who would be inducted
into the project individuals would go in
they would receive whatever kind of
training something along those lines and
then at some point their memories would
come back to them and when they did they
would basically defect from Weapon X the
Shiva's would be tasked with finding
them and either bringing them back in if
at all possible or simply neutralizing
them ie taking them out and so because
of this the Shiva's are designed to
withstand a pretty significant amount of
punishment now I want you to keep in
mind is that the Muramasa blade because
it's designed to basically nullify
healing
factors and this kind of a combination
of some of the hardest metals in
existence come on with a little bit of
mysticism and magic and so on and so
forth makes pretty quick work out of
this Shiva the problem is that Wolverine
comes to the realization whoever sipped
the Shiva was also the same person this
secretary was working for and so
ultimately they end up taking her out
now in response to this the federal
government taking shield off the whole
thing and saying look if you guys
couldn't even stop a rocket from crash
landing on the White House then we're
gonna take things into our own hands and
the result is the federal government
initiates the launch of Frank Simpson
also known as nuke now nuke has been a
long-standing member of the Marvel
Comics landscape for a really really
long time he's been around for ages and
ages and the cool thing about this is
that he was always one of these guys
that was kind of tied into the Weapon X
project and it really kind of goes back
to like 1989 with Wolverine vol 2 in
terms of you know the the kind of
stories that dealt with a little bit of
Wolverines origin different things along
those lines but again this is designed
to sort of consolidate all that
information and bring it together in a
easily accessible way and so this is
gonna kind of retell the origin of Frank
Simpson to a degree but the idea here is
a French Simpson as a guy over the
course of his life he's basically had
various aspects of his body replaced
with cybernetic implants and so at this
point in time he's more machine than
human but he still functions accordingly
according to the wishes of what the
federal government wants to do the other
half of this is that instead of having
him pop pills which are something that
he can either choose to do or choose not
to do what's happened here is they
basically replace the red and the blue
pills by putting in a second heart and
so what this does is it allows the
government to remotely decide whether he
gets amped up or whether he whether he
calms down now in terms of his actual
origin this is where things get kind of
interesting we actually sort of jumped
back to 1968 in the Vietnam War and this
is really just Wolverine operating as
part of weapon acts remember because
weapon acts in his earliest days was
kind of a joint venture between the CIA
and canada's department k what this men
is that wolverine as part of Weapon X
would carry out missions for Weapon X
and the result was that during these
early days when he was part of the black
ops team before he underwent the Weapon
X project the he was basically just kind
of carrying out these various missions
one of these missions dealt with the
idea of Frank Simpson being brought in
and kind of being transformed into a
sort of killer where he was kidnapped
during the Vietnam War and then you had
Wolverine who is part of the CIA and so
on and so forth operating as a Russian
advisor for the for the
honk what this meant was that he jumped
in and sort of going through and torture
a phrase Simpson but while he was doing
that he was planting a keyboard which
comes on the phrase of no VC and what
this means is that no VC was basically a
way of saying I'm not Vietcong the idea
behind this was that by planting that
phrase in there Frank Simpson when he
hears the phrase no VC will simply snap
he'll lose his mind and he'll just start
killing everything in the vicinity again
because of this what it also does is it
picks up with the silver samurai
conversing with the federal government
now silver samurai is a guy who's been
around for a really really long time I
want to say he was introduced in
daredevil number 11 back in like 1974
but he is a guy and I can never
pronounce his first name so it's like
it's like Kenny you Oh Chi pirata I
think is how you pronounce his first
name I apologize if I butchered that
I've never been able to pronounce his
first name but silver samurai is
actually the illegitimate son of a guy
named shin Jin Harada now a shin shin
Hirata is actually the father of a woman
named Mariko Yashida and Mariko Yashida
was at one point the fiancee of
Wolverine so it really all kind of goes
back to over in himself now of course
chin Jian ultimately met his demise
which meant that Mariko became the head
of Clan Yashida
and then following her death silver
samurai took up leadership of the group
but the idea behind this is that silver
samurai is very much honorbound you know
he's really one of these guys where he
sort of maintains this old-school code
of honor among his own people as well as
when he makes a vow of silence meaning
that he won't tell anybody anything
about what he's heard he takes it to the
grave so he's like one of the most
trustworthy people out there the kicker
to all this is that what he ends up
doing is kind of spilling the beans to
the federal government not in terms of
what he was asked not to tell but what
he was asked to tell in the sense that
Wolverine basically says look tell them
about the Muramasa blade and let them
know what's going on because in the end
it doesn't matter so this is really kind
of like Wolverine taunting the feds in a
lot of ways now of course silver samurai
basically says hey look there's this
thing called the Muramasa blade it's the
only thing capable of destroying
Wolverine but he asked me to tell you
this which is why I'm telling you it's
kind of interesting because this isn't
this isn't really serve like any major
purpose it's just kind of again a little
bit of a reminder that Wolverines life
and x span a great deal amount of time
in Marvel Comics and there's all of
these different characters that he's
impacted over the course of his life now
because of the fact that nuke has been
sent in what this means is that his
Wolverine basically confronting Frank
Simpson now again the
really kind of hits home at the nature
of the fact that Wolverines regain all
these memories from his own life and so
the reason why this matters is because
him confronting Frank Simpson is not
necessarily for the purpose of killing
him it's for the purpose of making
amends because Wolverine was the one
that transformed him into the person
that he is and the reason how that
happened is it all really kind of goes
back to the early days of his life and
this shows us how involved will reign
and the CIA and the Team X and even the
early stages of the Weapon X project it
shows us how it all kind of came
together when Frank Simpson was a little
kid the government had basically
targeted him for a project homegrown now
in truth there wasn't really a rhyme or
reason for it it was just we need
someone and so this kid's gonna be it
what ended up happening is the whole
project homegrown crew had basically
grabbed this woman and threw her into
Frank Simpsons family as a maid of sorts
now Frank Stinson himself was subject to
a very you know drunken abusive mother
and his father was more or less a coward
but the idea behind this was that
because he had been targeted this maid
had been brought in for the purpose of
surveying the family and deciding
whether or not it was a good choice and
because of the fact that Frank Simpson
in many ways came from a broken home
basically what it meant is that his
mother had died if his father had died
then he would just kind of be out there
and there would really not be anybody
else and so where this woman this made
kind of so you know subliminally
implants this idea of you should take
out your mom it's kind of left out there
in the background and then of course you
know where the father of Frank takes the
maid back home we end up having a wolf
range show up who basically shoots the
maid and then gives the gun to the
father and saying hey look this is your
gun it came through your house the whole
world is gonna believe you killed this
maid after trying to take advantage of
her and so the result is that the father
of Frank Simpson turns the weapon on
himself following this Wolverine goes
back to the house of Frank Simpson to
find that the subliminal implants of
this maid worked when Frank Simpson took
out his mom and so this basically leaves
him an orphan and every single sense of
the word and all loose ends are tied up
but because of the fact that this
combined with will rain visiting Frank
Simpson later on in his life when he had
enlisted in the Vietnam War and then
basically implanted the subliminal
wording into him basically meant that
from the time he was a child until the
time that he was an adult Wolverine had
quite literally crafted Frank Simpson
into the person that he is these these
memories sort of being restored back to
Wolverine basically means he's trying to
make amends here but because of the fact
that Frank Simpson spent so much of his
life being mentally tormented and
tortured by the federal government being
turned into
living weapon of sorts having various
biological parts of his body replaced
with cybernetics means that he's almost
completely inhuman now and so as a
response to this because of the fact
that this will inevitably result in the
destruction of Frank Simpson at least
that seems to be the case and because
the feds and you know basically invested
a hundred and thirty million dollars in
it what they end up doing is sending
Captain America in to neutralize
Wolverine to bring him in and to bring
Frank Simpson back so the Frank Simpson
can be recovered and it can still
continue to be used as a weapon now this
is interesting because this basically
pits a battle between Captain America
and Wolverine and this is actually a
topic of a pretty big battle that still
goes on on the Internet one of the big
questions people ask is who would win in
a fight Wolverine or Captain America
because we're Wolverine has studied all
manner of martial arts he doesn't quite
have the super-soldier enhancements that
Captain America has meaning Wolverines
body has not pushed to the peak of
physical perfection and he certainly
doesn't have the learning capabilities
that Captain America has at the same
time Wolverines been around for a few
hundred years and so he does have all
this wisdom and all this experience
under his belt and so even if they stand
on equal footing it does come by two
different means the cool thing about
this is that what it does is it does
actually put them on an equal footing
and that's what's cool about this is it
really just kind of says hey this is
probably how this would turn out Captain
America and Wolverine fighting at the
end of the day Captain America's not
really a better than Wolverine any more
than Wolverines better than Captain
America is we're just kind of the nature
of who they are Wolverines healing
factor combined with his adamantium
combined with all of his experience puts
him on par with Captain America who's
got a healing factor of his own not
quite on the same level as Wolverine but
you know his enhanced ability and speed
reflexes and so on and so forth and so
the fights pretty drag out it's pretty
knock-down drag-out and pretty brutal in
a lot of ways now of course Frank
Simpson who's basically kind of like
half a man at this point really just
kind of throws the Muramasa blade to
Captain America who in turn turns it on
Wolverine so this is kind of interesting
because at this point Wolverine doesn't
have a whole lot of an opportunity here
now the other half of this is that when
it comes to Marvel Comics with regards
to weapons Plus we've talked about this
before so if you're familiar with us
bear with me for a second when it comes
to weapons Plus that's the umbrella
organization under weapons plus you have
weapons 1 all the way up to 10
also known as Weapon X and even beyond
Weapon 10 yeah weapons 11 12 13 14 15
different things like that
by and large it was always believed that
when it came to the weapons Plus program
that it was
all rooted on the nature of Captain
America Captain America was weapon one
and the goal up until they found
Wolverine was to duplicate Captain
America and create a version of himself
with Wolverine it was Weapon X and
because of his healing factor combined
with the fact that he was the first
successful implantation of adamantium to
a person's bones grafted to their
skeleton the goal after Wolverine was to
not duplicate Captain America it was to
duplicate Wolverine one of the big
controversies in the story is that it
really kind of comes back and it says no
Frank Simpson was designed to duplicate
wove rain but that assumes that
Wolverine came before Frank Simpson
which isn't necessarily true and so
because this it is kind of interesting
because you remember chronologically
Wolverine was weapon ten Frank Simpson
was weapon seven so again it is it is
kind of weird it's a little bit of a
controversy here I mean it still works
for the purpose that it serves but it
also kind of begs the question how far
along was the planning for the character
of nuke by the time he was brought in a
project homegrown but again it's
Wolverine basically saying hey look they
were trying to duplicate you Captain
America they were trying to duplicate me
but in truth they were trying to
duplicate Captain America so again one
of those little oversights made by
Daniel way with writing of this story
but the fact remains here with Wolverine
kind of you know using the distraction
of Frank Simpson to overpower Captain
America to take the Muramasa blade where
it seems as though he's initially gonna
go after him instead we end up with the
arrival of Cyclops Hellion and Emma
Frost but the whole idea behind this is
that Emma Frost had previously tried to
enter the mind of Wolverine while he was
fighting Captain America the reason for
that was because by going through and
reading the mind of Wolverine as well as
kind of you know looking around the
world or looking around the world as it
exists Emma Frost started coming to
these realizations but there's a whole
other side of this equation that
Wolverine doesn't know about
specifically the son of Wolverine
Wolverine does not know that he has a
son now of course this also goes in and
grabs things like Silver Fox silver Fox
was kind of an on you know in an older
standard when it came to the Wolverine
comics hadn't really been referenced for
quite some time and she was never really
essential the only real role she served
was kind of like the reason why it is
that Wolverine is sabertooth
hate each other so much so if this was a
video on the topic of Wolverine and
Sabretooth and certainly it would be
vastly important but because it's not
because it kind of deals with the early
days of Wolverine with regards to him
learning about his own past and kind of
you know consolidating all this
information to the realization that his
son's alive Silver Fox was really just
kind of a person that will rain fell in
love with for a while
Sabretooth ended up showing up and
taking out Silver Fox now the motivation
for why Sabretooth did that Ruby
important later on down the line
especially when we get into the
introduction of the character Romulus
but for right now
he was just a person that took out
Silver Fox and it kind of engendered a
hatred between Wolverine and Sabretooth
now of course you know Wolverine was
overpowered in the experience he was
kind of left for dead and that was
really about it but this kind of led him
on the into this path led him into the
circle of coming across all these
various people and sort of set him on
the path of becoming part of Team X the
CIA you know all those different things
like that you know kind of bringing all
that back together again and so on and
so forth but again with this whole
scenario because of the fact that you
know Wolverine realizes that he does
have a son his son has been brought into
the Weapon X project his son it's
basically where Wolverine was however
many years ago when he was originally
brainwashed and part of that whole
system Wolverine comes to the
realization this is eventually gonna
boil down to him fighting his son and so
if that happens and he has the Muramasa
blade one of them will use it to kill
the other and so as a result he hands it
over to Cyclops he said he says I do not
want this played with me because I do
not want to be forced to kill my own son
assuming it comes down to that now of
course this also kind of gets in tap by
Emma Frost that will rain son hates that
which of course you know we'll see that
later on with the character of Dakin and
how all that unfolds but again you know
the Wolverine origin stories were very
much designed to sort of introduce these
small little nuances here in there
everything will build on everything else
and so we'll go back and we'll reference
this first story well reference the
story after this you know as we get
further on down the line we'll end up
finding out that the Wolverine origin
line of comics is very important
especially once we get to like dark
Wolverine the rise of day Kent the
events of Dark Reign the dark era of the
x-men all those different things like
that it's all gonna play a pretty
significant role but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain and make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
robb cork if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]